There’s something about the experimental
nature of science that attracts the crazies.
You just won’t believe what despicable,
weird and just downright evil things these
pioneers of the bizarre have done.
1.
Sergei S. Bryukhonenko, was a Soviet scientist,
and head of the Research Institute of Experimental
Surgery, during the Stalin era.
Now that’s a recipe for a mad scientist
if ever I heard one.
Sergei was the inventor of the first artificial
heart machine, which he called the autojektor,
a machine that’s purpose was to sustain
life through artificial means.
It was used to help perform the first Soviet
open heart surgery.
Seems to be going pretty well so far doesn’t
it, well this is the bit where it goes weird.
Sergei was obsessed with mutilating animals
then seeing how long he could keep their dismembered
heads alive.
His laboratory was filled with dead, mostly
headless, dogs.
I told you it gets weird.
Sergei’s most infamous experiment was documented
on video and it involved decapitating a dog,
which he then placed on a table.
Sergei then managed to bring the head back
to life using his homemade life support machine.
The severed dog’s head was fully responsive
and it even accepted a treat from the staff.
The original recording of the experiment can
be found on the internet, but I should warn
you it’s not for the faint hearted.
2.
During World War II, thousands of human experiments
were carried out by nazi scientists under
Hitler’s instruction.
The goal of these experiments was to discover
new ways to aid German military personnel
whom had been injured during combat, and also
to discover radical new medical treatments
to advance Hitler’s ideology.
The leader of these experiments was Dr. Josef
Mengele.
Who earned himself the nickname the “Angel
of Death” for the atrocities he carried
out.
When new inmates arrived at Auschwitz, Mengele
would select which were to be gassed and which
would be taken to the laboratory to conduct
his inhumane experiments on.
Josef Mergele was obsessed by twins, he would
often attempt to stitch the flesh, blood vessels
and organs of twins together in an attempt
to create Siamese twins.
But his subjects often contracted gangrene
and died after a couple of days of unimaginable
pain.
Josef performed experiments such as putting
victims into pressure chambers, castration,
freezing subjects to death, removal of organs
and limbs and even performing sex change operations.
Most of the victims were murdered following
the experiment, if they didn’t straight
up die from the experiment that is.
3.
During the second Sino-Japanese War and World
War II the Imperial Japanese Army setup a
covert biological and chemical research and
development base called Unit 731.
They told the locals it was a water treatment
plant, but that guise must have fallen apart
pretty quickly once the locals realised that
the screams of tortured humans sounds remarkably
different than running water.
Microbiologist, and medical officer Shirō
Ishii, was the director of Unit 731.
He committed numerous atrocities at Unit 731,
in the name of science, including: vivisection
of living people without anaesthetic, including
pregnant women, dismembering peoples limbs
then reattaching them to other parts of their
body, injecting subjects with deadly diseases
to study the effects and even using people
as live test targets for grenades and flame
throwers.
However after the war ended Shirō Ishii never
spent any time in jail for his atrocities,
because he was granted immunity by the US
government.
Some believe this is because the US made a
pact with Japan during the war to help cover
up Unit 731, in exchange for medical knowledge
of their findings.
4.
At number 4 is Sidney Gottlieb, but he had,
possibly the coolest alias of all the evil
scientists, his colleagues referred to him
as Dr. Feelgood.
He was an American military psychiatrist with
a Ph.D in chemistry.
During the Cold War the CIA hired him to help
develop biological weapons and poisons to
use against the Russians.
But Gottlieb’s only answer to taking out
America’s enemies was to poison them all.
Gottlieb proposed the idea of killing Fidel
Castro with either a poisoned cigar, a poisoned
fountain pen, or a poisoned wetsuit, whichever
was easiest, it turns out none was the answer,
since he’s still alive.
Gottlieb’s other unsuccessful poisoning
attempts included an Iraqi general and the
prime minister of the Democratic Republic
of the Congo.
But that’s just the tip of Sidney Gottlieb’s
weird iceberg.
He was also the head of the MKULTRA project.
Which studied the possibility of using LSD
to mind control one’s enemies.
They were interested if the psychedelic drug
could be used to break a person’s mind for
the purpose of interrogation.
So Gottlieb and his colleague’s spent a
large portion of their time getting high on
acid.
But they soon realised they would need test
subjects other than themselves.
However instead of inviting willing subjects
to get high on LSD, Gottlieb instead travelled
around America slipping LSD into people’s
drinks and observing the effects.
He mainly targeted prostitutes and drug addicts.
5.
Next up is American psychologist, Harry Harlow,
he had the nickname “Monkey Torturer”,
you just know that this guy qualifies for
this video with a name like that.
He was obsessed with finding out “what is
love”, and for some unknown reason he decided
the best way to do that was by torturing baby
monkeys.
Yes, that’s right baby monkeys.
To achieve his goal Harlow invented a range
of monkey torturing devices.
One of his most infamous, he lovingingly referred
to as the “rape rack”.
Harlow would use his rape rack device to force
monkeys to mate.
He also had a device he called the “iron
maiden”.
But perhaps his most controversial experiment
was called the “pit of despair”.
Harlow would place a baby monkey in a small
isolated chamber for up to a year, without
any contact with another living creature.
As a result, the monkeys all became psychotic
and never recovered.